We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2, David P..
Now, I actually don't know what this person's
talking about.
I see if you can understand what it is that
they're referring to.
Take a listen.
David Pakman.
Don't you think abortion is going to be the
key issue that destroys the Democratic coalition
come November?
Thank you.
I don't know what.
They mean in the sense that the Democratic
coalition.
First of all, the country more than ever approves
of abortion.
In most cases, the country more than ever
believes that abortion should be legal in
most cases at a higher rate than at any point
in history.
Since the Roe v. Wade era, that's number one.
Number two, I didn't think that there was
really much debate about this on the Democratic
side, so I don't know what the caller is referring
to.
I also don't even think abortion is really
going to be a big issue as we get into November
very often.
You know, in general election debates, there
will be questions about Supreme Court justices.
Would you would you nominate anyone to the
court that might overturn Roe v. Wade or just
support for Roe v. Wade, a figure as a prerequisite
for anybody you would recommend to the court,
nominate to the court?
I don't see abortion playing a large role
here at all.
And I genuinely don't know what the caller
is talking about.
So I'd love to hear from you.
What do you think they're referring to?
Make sure that you are signed up to the David
Pakman Show newsletter.
You can sign up at David Pakman dot com Thursday,
April 9, one day membership special.
We lost three hundred and eighty nine members
in March because of the virus and people tightening
the belt.
We've lost a few dozen already in April, April
9th.
We're doing a one day membership special biggest
discount of the year to try to recover some
of those lost members.
Sign up at David Pakman dot com for my newsletter.
You'll be notified at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
on Thursday.
And of course, don't miss today's bonus show
with producer Pat.
Joining us from his second location in two
weeks after a big ceiling implosion took place
last week.
We told that story and Pat is with us from
another.
This time, a secured, undisclosed location.
We'll speak to you on the phone.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.